MALE SPEAKER: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is
primarily a question and
answer show.
So if any of you out there would
like to ask questions.
IDO GREEN: Hello and
welcome to GDLI--
Google Developer Live Israel.
Thank you for joining us.
Today we are going to speak
about mobile web apps and
what, as a font developer, we
should think about when we are
coming to develop a new product
or a new service or a
new layout to our website
or web app.
And of course, we want it to be
available in all the mobile
devices that are out there.
One common denominator of this
we see again and again in all
the devices that we have today,
and certainly in the
near future in new devices, is
one great piece of software,
which is the browser.
On most of the devices today,
we have Chrome.
And that's really good news in
the sense that you have the
latest and greatest
in terms of HTML5
APIs that are supported.
And in this short presentation,
I'll try to go
over the different main points
that you want to think about
when you are creating a new
mobile web app in terms of the
design, the building blocks,
and the tools or libraries
that you might want to
leverage, and not
reinvent the wheel.
Without further ado, let me
jump into the slides.
And if you'll have any
questions, I'll be more than
happy to try and answer them
at the end of the show.
So here in the first slide,
of course, we are using
geolocation.
And just do view source, and
you'll see how easy it is to
tap into the special ability
that we have today with mobile
devices, and then just to get
from the browser, the location
of the user, and offer them
immediately more relevant
information based on
the geoinformation
that we have on them.
If you have any questions during
the show or after it,
you're most welcome to come and
Ping me on G+ or Twitter.
All the slides that I'm going
through are now live under
ido-green.appspot.com.
And of course, we'll have a
summary with a transcript in
my blog after the show.
If you have some hashtags,
those are one of the most
popular ones that I'm using in
order to see what's new there
and to keep myself up to date
with new things that are
coming very rapidly into
the ecosystem.
So what we'll try to cover in
the next 25, 30 minutes will
be just to give a short
brief of the state of
the mobile web today.
Then we'll talk a little bit
about design philosophy, what
are the main things that we want
to consider and evaluate
when we are coming to design
a new mobile web app.
Then we'll give some best
practices and tips about how
to build a mobile web app.
And here is a link of a very,
very cool new game that Chrome
Experiments launched.
And the beauty here is that
basically we're having the
remote control in our
phone, in our Chrome
on the mobile device.
And we're using the
larger screen.
It could be Chrome on
the TV or Chrome on
your laptop or desktop.
And the game is running
on the bigger screen.
But the remote control for the
game is on your phone.
And that's, in a way, just
starting to gain the best of
both worlds in terms
of slickness.
Last but not least, we'll try
to give some tips and best
practices to save you time and
effort and make you more
productive.
One little warning, many things
that we are speaking
here-- and yeah, that's a very,
very cool new effect
that we've been using for the
past two years, actually--
is just to tell you that we are
on the bleeding edge here
in terms of some of
the features.
So if we're thinking or talking
about certain things,
please go to places like
caniuse.com, or any other site
that's giving you a nice set
of things to see which
browsers, in terms of your
users, are using them.
And then you could evaluate
if you want to use
this specific API.
For instance, let's take
drag and drop.
You can see immediately which
browser are supporting it, and
which mobile browsers aren't
supporting it.
So you'll know exactly
what users
could enjoy it or whatnot.
Another really nice way to
think about it is to use
libraries like Modernizer and
then have feature detection
and not browser sniffing,
which is not good.
And with the feature detection,
basically you will
know exactly what are the set
of features or capabilities
that certain mobile
app is giving you.
And then based on that, you
could use responsive design
and progressive enhancement in
order to make sure that some
of the users will be able to
be productive, even if they
are working on older phone,
while if your user is coming
from the latest greatest in
terms of the hardware, you
could offer them more, and your
app will work smoothly,
better in terms of performance,
and maybe have
some nice set of features
that aren't
supported on older devices.
We jumped into some
mobile trains.
Well, the main outcome
from this slide is
that mobile is big.
And mobile usage is actually
going to overtake desktop.
Basically we see the pace
growing rapidly.
And it might be even before
we reach 2014.
Another important thing here
is we have already nice
research from third party
companies-- so take it with a
grain of salt--
about seeing that actually
the mobile web is here.
It's here to stay.
And lots of users
are using it.
Here's a specific case
that Chitika did.
We see it happening in the ISO
world, happening right now
pretty rapidly.
When we're speaking about mobile
browser, the good news
is that most of them got very
nice elegant browsers that are
supporting quite a lot
of HTML5 features.
In terms of the coverage, it's
around 95% of web kit.
And that's including
iOS, Android,
BlackBerry, and some others.
The main features that we are
still missing are WebGL, Web
Audio API, that probably is
coming really soon in some of
the browsers, and Shared
Web Workers.
In progress, we have today
nice cool things like the
Camera API and IndexedDB which
is a full blown NoSQL database
that we have today in
Chrome for Android.
For other ecosystems,
like iOS, you'll
want to use Web SQL.
But since this spec is
deprecated from 2010, you
might want to use something like
launcher, and then have
the ability to switch on the fly
between the database that
you're working.
So if you'll use launcher, and
we'll have the link to this
library at the end of the
slides, you could work with
both Web SQL IndexedDB.
And if other browser are
supporting, let's say, local
storage, you'd be able
to work with that.
So that's a nice way to approach
things, and then
enjoy both worlds in supporting
several ecosystems,
just to make sure that you'll
be able to work with offline
first and offer your users the
best environment and best
experience with your
search and app.
This is just a quick graph to
show how quickly we're seeing
Android going up, and how WebKit
is supported on all the
major platforms, as I mentioned
before, Android,
iPhone, BlackBerry, iPod
Touch, et cetera.
When we come into the old debate
between web and native,
it's always refreshing to
think about using and
leveraging the best
tools for the job.
So in terms of being close to
the metal and using all of the
great features that you have
today, let's take, for
example, on Android platform,
you probably want to create
native apps so it will work as
close as possible to the
metal, and will give you
all the full range
of different APIs.
The web, on the other end,
is a unified platform.
As we mentioned before, you
have it on different
ecosystems.
In all of them, you'll
have the browser.
And even on all the forms, you
do have the browsers that will
be able to read your HTML and
show the user what you want
them to consume.
Native, of course, is
a moving target.
And we're seeing it being
improved very rapidly,
although we're seeing
the web pushing the
boundaries again and again.
And the APIs guys are getting
closer and closer.
This standardization on the web
is moving a bit slowly.
But the good news, or the half
full part of the cup is that
it's catching up.
And the pace is getting
better and better.
Here there's a link to a Scott
Jason presentation about what
he thinks mobile web will look
like in the next few years.
And I highly encourage
you to check it out.
It's really worth
your 45 minutes.
Here are some really nice
examples, just to see what
others are doing there.
"Financial Times," it's, of
course, a media company.
And their app is really a nice
way to show you how you could
tap into the offline
world with a full
blown mobile web app.
Workflowy, it's to do list on
steroids, or actually a way
for you to organize your things
and thoughts on lists,
also working very nicely.
And of course, mobile Twitter,
which is another good example.
And we have plenty of
other examples.
I'll have links to how you could
gain more ideas in the
next slide.
Here's a link that shows us
another research company that
basically users want to work
with the mobile web.
They are using the browsers
more and more.
And in some cases, it makes
perfect sense for them to open
the browser, launch your
dedicated web app to a
specific task or goal, achieve
what they wanted, and move on.
Some bold, good examples,
we mentioned Twitter.
Gmail, of course, it's a full
blown mobile web app that are
working really nicely and giving
you really nice special
features in terms of the
capabilities, the offline
features, and all the
other great benefits
that we have in Gmail.
Another nice way to think about
this, like with this app
for Footspotting, where you have
a limited real estate,
try to do your best to tap into
what the user is wanting
to achieve with your
dedicated app.
So in that example, we certainly
don't need any
footer, header, sidebar,
or things that
will clutter the app.
Very clean approach.
And you can see more and more
way of thinking in those
words, in apps like
[INAUDIBLE]
and other really
nice examples.
So let's try and speak
briefly about design.
First, in the old days, we have
this notion of going to
the designer.
He's or she's working
with the Photoshop,
giving us the assets.
Then we need someone to
cut the HTML and CSS.
And very cluttered, not truly
elegant or agile methodology.
Today, I tried to break it here
into pieces that actually
allow us to work much faster,
iterate faster, and see how
we're prototyping and getting
ideas out there as soon as we
can, just to validate them
before we are going to the
last phase of production.
So today, you'll see more and
more people doing design
through wire frames, or even
trying to mock up how it will
look like pretty quickly.
And there's plenty of online
tools that make you
productive with it.
The basic asset is to put the
ideas on paper, on board, on a
napkin, or on any platform that
you want, and then quite
quickly to sketch it with HTML
and a bit of CSS, just to see
how it will look like,
how it will feel.
Then we want to achieve a bit
of responsiveness and logic.
And probably those cases will
go to the upper right block
here, and add some JavaScript
to add our own
magic to the prototype.
And from there, basically we're
going to the polish
phase, which I call that the
important phase that separate
the true professional one's from
that amateur ones, where
we want you to work as slick as
we can as fast as we can.
And this is actually a place
where we are going back to the
scheduled prototype, but
want to iterate over it
as fast as we can.
Of course we want a test-driven
development in a
way, or to have a final phase of
continuous integration, and
to do some really testing on
real devices, just to make
sure that we have a nice
coverage with the 28-year
rules, or any other rules that
you want to do in order to
make sure that the vast majority
of your users will be
able to be productive
and enjoy your app.
And last but not least, of
course, we want to push it to
production, have our alpha beta
release candidate, and,
of course, the first
version out there.
But as we all know, today, the
end of the trip is just one
stepping stone in it.
We'll want to iterate again
and again and have more
features over time.
When we're coming to speak about
it, basically the one
fundamental shifting in thinking
is that we're not
speaking about pages anymore.
We're more working on this
one page application.
And we want to make sure that
we do the best with the
limited real estate and give a
set of guidance or a set of
tools for users to achieve
their goals with maximum
efficiency.
We'll want to use components.
So we don't want to reinvent
the wheel.
And the web as a platform,
actually, is going to give us
just that in the near future.
So now, if you want to check the
water, just try AngularJS
with directives, which basically
giving you a really
nice way to think about reusing
your code, don't
repeat yourself, and just
leveraging things that you
already did in the past.
As we mentioned, in mobile and,
of course, in mobile web,
less is more in most
of the cases.
Because we don't have a lot of
real estate and the user got
some fat fingers in most of
the cases, we'll want few
buttons, few words, just to make
sure that we are aiming
or making the life of our users
as easy as possible, as
efficient as possible.
Here is just a nice example of
[? Path ?] and what they did
with their menu button.
And if you'll search on GitHub,
you'll find lots of
repositories that give you just
that, nice interactions
of collapsing the different
options from the bottom left
corner back and forth, a very
nice way to think about.
And another two tips here to
remember, that on mobile
devices we do have the landscape
that is changing.
So we want to do the best in
order to use media queries and
just be able to communicate
it to the user.
And of course, using just
Photoshop is not as efficient
as we wanted to see.
And in lots of cases, we
probably could do less with
Photoshop and mobile.
We're just prototyping
and using HTML,
JavaScript, and CSS.
Here are some really nice bold
examples, that you really
don't want to reinvent
the wheel.
You want to be inspire.
And pttrns.com and
mobile-patterns are just those
two sites that give you the
ability to go and see what
others did when they needed a
map application or a long
list, or any other things
that they wanted to do.
And it just will save you time
and efforts, and make sure
that you'll be able to do
nice things with them.
Let's just, for the sake of
argument, open it so we'll be
able to see.
So here are some
recently added.
But let's say that we want to
see what interesting things
people have done with lists.
You have a very nice collection
of things here just
to inspire you and to
take it from there.
And of course, the nice
example of a path.
So we wanted to do this quick
sketch-up to see how things
are working.
And here are a few nice
online tools.
I will just add that on top of
these tools, you could go
today to jQuery mobile site,
and you'll have basically
[INAUDIBLE] there that lets you
mock up real quickly and
get even the structure of the
HTML from your mock, really
nice and easy to use.
Balsamiq is, of course, a very
popular, nice web app that
gives you the ability to do
those things efficiently, and
others, modern web apps
that are there.
And you could retrieve them
from the Chrome Web Store.
One thing to remember after we
did our sketching is that you
want to make sure that what you
designed is doing the best
for the phone or
for the tablet.
They are not the same.
And one thing that we could
probably save ourself is the
notion of let's aim and do
whatever we can with all the
devices that have 4" by 3"
screens or 16" by 9", just to
make sure that we are not going
too crazy with the media
queries to adjust our app to
each and every device.
But a nice example that you see
here with Flipboard, check
their app on a tablet
and on a phone.
It's completely different.
Even the ability to do the flip
itself, they didn't use
the muscle memory that users
have in the tablet, which is
horizontal reason flip.
And they choose on the phone
to do it vertically because
it's just a better experience.
And that's a great example to do
what is best for our users,
and, of course, validate
it with testing.
When we're speaking about
adaptive apps, apps that are
less bind into a specific
screen, we're talking
basically about doing a re-paint
and refresh of our
DOM, of our structure based on
the real estate that we're
getting in the app itself.
And we know that one of the
main pitfalls is that it's
really hard to use the same DOM
tree for all form factors.
So we're seeing today a nice
interesting debate between,
OK, let's have one DOM and
just use different media
queries with different CSS.
Or let's do some sniffing in
advance to see which device is
coming, and then just make sure
that we are sending back
the dedicated HTML CSS and
JavaScript that will do the
best for this specific medium.
When we're speaking about all
those adaptive apps, we want
to use some sort of a temperate
library, in order to
make sure that our DOM
refreshing and repainting will
be as efficient as possible.
And we'll see in the next slides
how we could do that.
And of course, when we're using
responsive design, we
want to use things like read
box, Flexbox, and not, of
course, absolute position or
relative position, because it
won't work nicely on the
different devices as we have
today, not to mention
future devices.
When we're using the CSS3 new
grid layouts or Flexbox
layout, we could do ourself a
favor and just focus on those
form factors, which will make
our life a bit easier, and are
still very good for the vast
majority of the users.
Here is the link
for [INAUDIBLE]
site, which contains a huge
amount of really nice
information.
And of course, media queries,
which is letting you see
different examples in the wild
and getting some ideas how
your web app or website should
look on a desktop, tablet, and
a mobile device.
Let's jump real quick
to building.
Of course, when we're shifted
more and more logic to the
client side, we want some clear
separation between our
data and our views.
And that's why we see a
flourishing in all the MV-star
frameworks today.
And if in the past we used to
have this logic in the server,
and just sending to the client
HTML pages that represent this
logic, we're seeing more and
more movement of a thicker
client that contain more
and more knowledge.
And that's come with the notion
of offline first, when
basically we want the user to be
productive, even when there
is no connection or a
flaky connection.
Just a clear scanner to see what
we're talking about when
we're speaking about model view
controller framework, and
specifically in the case of
mobile web app, we do want our
views to have the dedicated
view for each form factor.
So we'll have one view for
desktop, maybe another one for
TV here on the right
side, and of course
for tablets and phone.
We could share the same
controller to hold our data
and to update our view.
And here is a link to what
[INAUDIBLE] did, which is a
great, great thing in terms of
comparing the different MVC
frameworks that are out there.
Another nice code snippet that
you could take here is to do
something like that in order
to understand which form
factor the user is using, and
then make sure that your code
and other goodness
is bring to them.
And I see here people
are saying
dedicate view for Glass.
Absolutely.
I can't agree more, actually.
In terms of the products
of choice, basically
we'll see it again.
We had it in the service side a
few years back, when you see
a huge flourishing in all
the MVC frameworks
in Java, for instance.
And now we have the same with
JavaScript and the client side
MVC frameworks.
Here we don't jump into
it, because we don't
have too much time.
I'll just mention those three
really bold examples.
And with five seconds promotion
to Angular, I really
encourage you to check it, not
because it's an open source
project that started in Google,
of course not, just
because it's a true passion of
mine to see how people are
thinking about dynamic HTML, not
static HTML, and how you
have dependency [? injection ?]
and test-driven development
in a JavaScript framework.
Really, really cool stuff.
This is one of the compression
tables that you'll see if
you'll go to the link and the
work, the hard work that
[INAUDIBLE]
did.
I highly encourage you to see.
And basically even here, don't
take my word to AngularJS or
to the wisdom of the crowd,
quote unquote, that's going
with Backbone.
Just do small research for
yourself and choose the best
tool for the job.
The TodoMVC, of course, what we
mention, the link is here.
When we want to run our complex
app, and we want to do
some DOM manipulation, we know
that we need to do it as
efficient as possible.
And here the big secret, which
is basically not a secret at
all, is to use a JavaScript
templating mechanism.
Nicely, we have it now baked
into Chrome and hopefully
other modem browser
real quick.
So this is the link
with [INAUDIBLE].
So you'll be able to tap
into it and to read.
It's a very good tutorial
that Eric Bidelman
did on HTML5 Rock.
But here we'll just show you how
you could do it even today
that will basically support
all the browsers.
We're using an embedded and a
certain new type to make sure
that our templating engine
will work with it.
And we'll bundle it
into the HTML.
And then we could use several
templating engines.
So here I use mustache.js, which
is a very popular choice
of the logic-less templating
engine.
And you could see the example,
even if you never saw it in
advance, that what we have here
is basically three parts.
One is the templating.
And if you'll move your head to
the right, you'll see why
they call it mustache, because
of these little guys.
And here we'll just declare
what we're going to
have in each spot.
Then we're using a payload
of our JSON.
And the result, what the
templating engine will put in
our page will be this mark-up
that the browser
will know how to render.
Another cool thing that we
should leverage today when we
are approaching the world of
mobile web app is some new
CSS3 products.
And basically I'm talking
about [INAUDIBLE]
which giving us some goodies,
not really a synthetic sugar
but more of real tools to work
with, like variables, like
nesting, and mixing and
inheritance in CSS.
So your ability to work more
efficiently with CSS will gain
you more hour of sleep
and happy users.
And one nice thing to remember
is that when you're working
with it, basically it's easy
today even to debug it because
you have the ability to go
quickly in Chrome Dev tools
and tap into the source itself
of the CSS or the source code,
with Map Source, of course.
Some best practices
for the layout--
of course avoid the horrible
tables that have been with us
in the late '90s.
No absolute position, not
even relative position.
We do want to use something
like the Flexbox.
Why?
Because we basically are able
to communicate the browser
exactly what we want
it to achieve.
Things like, OK separate now
those boxes and make the
middle boxes twice the size from
the other boxes, or make
all of them in a row or
a column, et cetera.
It's all trivial with Flexbox,
and just challenging you to do
it with the regular CSS.
It will be much, much harder,
and more code for you to read
later when you're coming to
maintain the web app.
This little example is just to
show you how you can control
here on the orientation.
So here it's horizontal.
If the user is flipping the
phone, you could do it
vertical as well.
And very easy to control
the different
components of your Flexbox.
The one caveat here is
that we're talking
about the new Flexbox.
And there are relatively really
few changes that you
need to pay attention to.
This is just to show you how you
could easily control them.
And really nice talks on
developer.google.com/live
showing you more how
to work with it.
Some tips to remember is that
if you want to have a fixed
position for your head or
footers, it used to be a big
no-no in all the browsers.
Now both on Mobile Safari and,
of course, Chrome for Android,
you just need to do
position fix.
If you have an element that you
want to scroll elements
inside it, just do
overall scroll.
And last but not least, if you
want this nice responsive
acceleration, deceleration
scrolling in WebKit, and as we
mentioned at the beginning, 90%
plus of the browser are
supporting it, just do WebKit
overflow scrolling touch, and
you'll be able to gain
this nice ability.
One important thing to note
about touch is that it's very
different for our mouse.
We need to make sure that
we are listening
to the right events.
And one common pitfall is to
bind events to the click.
On mobile and touch screens,
of course the browser will
wait 300 milliseconds, because
it needs to distinguish one
click to two clicks.
And this is why I put the link
here to Fast Click Library
that the "Financial Times"
did, actually [INAUDIBLE]
that was bought by the
"Financial Times," and which
basically listened to the touch
start in making sure
that it's much smoother and
much more responsive.
And the other good link here is
just to best practices of
developing for multi-touch
blog posts
that Boris Smus wrote.
When we're coming to the world
of offline, and specifically
mobile web apps, we want to make
sure that our app will
work even when there's
no connection.
Why?
Because in the cases where we
have a flaky connection, or on
an airplane or submarine, the
user could be productive.
And a great example is
[INAUDIBLE], of course.
And today, lucky for us, we have
all the building blocks.
So I know that they are not
perfect and they could
improve over time.
And I see the guys that are
mentioning and trying to point
their fingers to some
known candidates.
But here they will get better.
And actually we are able to work
with them today, so why
not tap in to them?
To storing [? updates ?]
of course, we have all
the good things here.
And to know when to do the sync,
basically the main API
that we want to use
is Navigator
online or Window online.
As I mentioned before, Lawnchair
is one good library
to use when we want to make
sure that we all doing the
best with the certain app or
certain browser that our app
have to use, which will
basically give us the ability
to enjoy all those nice APIs,
depending on what the
different browser on the user
device is supporting.
And here is a short tutorial
that I wrote a while back to
help people converge from WebSQL
to IndexedDB, just
because WebSQL is a
depricated API.
So you don't want to start
a new project with it.
One thing that held mobile
web apps was the
ability to debug them.
It wasn't too easy.
Of course, for Chrome for
Android, your life is good.
And you could do lots of things
immediately and have
basically Chrome Dev tools
and work with them very
efficiently on your
mobile as well.
But for other platforms, we
have JS Console that Remy
Sharp wrote, and all the other
good links here that you are
most welcome to check, and
other nice things.
I don't know how many people
know, but basically in Chrome
browser we have a
server as well.
So you could run it with this
remote debugging port, which
is basically part of WebKit,
and have the ability to tap
and run Dev Tool, or connect
your Dev Tool to client
browsers, and again, gain all
the capabilities and the
benefits that we have
in Chrome Dev Tools.
Testing, MVC or the clear
separation between our data
and our views allow us,
basically, to test our models.
And QUnit is one
great example.
When we're coming to test our
views, it's much more
challenging.
And here are some good
links to help you
achieve that as well.
Speed--
[INAUDIBLE]
all the recent studies shows
form all the big names, like
Amazon, Facebook,
Google, Yahoo,
every millisecond count.
And you do want your users
happy and smiling.
And that's why you need
to focus on mobile web
performance, and web performance
as a whole.
And luckily for all
of us, [INAUDIBLE]
on developer.google.com/live is
doing great shows about web
performance and pushing
the web faster.
And I highly encourage
you to see his shows.
Really, really quality,
great stuff there.
When we're coming to
optimization, there are a few
tools that are helping
us today.
Blaze.io, that is part of Akamai
let us know exactly
what's going with our
apps from different
places in the world.
And this other link here is
Mobile Perf for bookmarketlet
that Steve Souders did to enable
you to tap into a lot
of information from your mobile
web app, and then
analyze it, of course,
on the desktop.
And SPDY.
SPDY is basically a new
experimental protocol designed
by Google to reduce the
latency of web pages.
And it's in Chrome.
So you could use it today.
It will work much faster
for your users.
And you have mode
SPDY in a patch.
So if you have control of your
servers, I highly encourage
you to check it out.
The link here will show you how
easy it is to install it
and customize it.
Last but not least, some
tips and tricks.
We have today few tech stocks
that choose the route of
convention over configuration.
And some really brilliant people
with lots of experience
on their hands choose the best
tools out there to make your
life more productive.
And Yeoman and Thorax are just
two bold examples that I
highly encourage you to check
out when you are coming to
start a new project.
If you are developing on
iOS, there's a new--
it's not new, actually-- but a
nice way to be able to see
more loggin, and that's by
setting Safari developer and
then just opening the console.
To simulate touch events,
you have it today
in Chrome Dev Tools.
And let me showing you
how you could do it.
If you'll come here to the
bottom right corner and click
on the setting, you'll
be able to open the
setting of the Dev Tools.
Probably for you it will
open in general.
But if you'll go to Override
here, you'll need to click
here on Emulate Events.
Let me make it bigger.
And once you do that, you'll be
able to listen to all the
different touch events and make
sure that your mobile web
apps is answering them.
It's not a replacement to
testing it on simulator or on
a physical device.
But it's just making the
developer life more productive
when they could use it while
they're developing it, and
make sure that at least you're
answering all the right events
in the right DOM and using the
audit and performance tab in
the Chrome Dev Tools to make
sure that you are optimizing
even before you are reaching
the physical device.
Privatization, of course, it's
very, very important.
And like any app, we want to
focus on the MVP or the task
that you want to user to
achieve with maximum
efficiency.
Take advantage, of course, of
mobile specific functionality,
like the geolocation, like the
camera, things that are very
important for users.
And of course, not
to mention touch.
When you're building to the
mobile platform, always think
about speed, because it's
really, really different from
what users are expecting or
getting when they're using
their desktops or laptops.
And of course, optimization
don't start it
before you need to.
But do pay attention and
do it as the last step.
So to keep yourself updated with
Chrome as a platform, we
have Chrome today on mobile
devices, tablets, desktops,
laptops, and TVs, that's
a great site to
check Chrome status.
All the latest and greatest in
terms of HTML5 APIs are there.
And you could see exactly which
Chromium browser will
support them, or supporting
them already.
Another great site to keep
yourself updated, it's
updates.html5.rock.
As you can see, we're keeping
it fresh all the time.
And here are just a list of
resources that you might want
to check and leverage
after our show.
So that's basically
what I had.
If we have any questions, this
is a great time to ask them.
Just feel free over the chat
or through the handout.
So I see one question here
from [INAUDIBLE]
is for newbies, "what would you
recommend to start with
for mobile web development?"
So let's go--
I see [INAUDIBLE]
already answered him
about slide 34.
Let's see.
So I will actually answer
it in two ways.
One is, of course, you want to
check Yeoman or Thorax in
terms of the full stacks
that you want to start
from the ground up.
Those stacks will give you the
best practices in terms of the
libraries, the tools, and the
ability to compile and
optimize your app itself.
By as a newbie, I will go and
just check what jQuery Mobile
or [INAUDIBLE]
are doing.
And those are really good
frameworks slash libraries to
start working with them.
And of course, you have Twitter
Bootstrap Responsive
as another great
starting point.
They're basically giving you
a nice CSS template, a
responsive template to start
your mobile web app.
An in Twitter Bootstrap, for
instance, you have also a nice
range of jQuery plug-ins that
allow you to have all the
common functionality that
you might need.
jQuery Mobile is a really nice
one, because they already did
lots leg works for you by
checking and making sure that
the platform itself will
work on a really
wide range of devices.
And [INAUDIBLE], of course,
are doing lots of fun nice
things in terms of the touch
library that they have.
It's more complicated,
I agree.
But if you are building a
complicated app that your
users will spend a lot of time
in it, it's a really nice
library that will serve you in
the end of the day lots of
wheels that you'll probably
need to reinvent yourself.
[? Dodger ?]
Mobile is another
good candidate.
And I'm sure there are
plenty of others that
I'm not aware of.
Those are the ones that
I played in the past.
But you are most welcome to
check and let me know.
And I'll be able to update
actually those slides and the
blog post that we'll have as
a summary for this talk.
Any other questions
or comments?
OK, guys, so thank
you very much.
Oh, how did I create
this presentation?
Just do view source.
It's all HTML, HTML5.
You are most welcome
to take it.
The structure of the
presentation itself is sitting
on code.google.com.
Just have fun.
OK, guys, thank you very much.
And be strong.
Until next time, bye-bye.